bonjour et bienvenue dans leurs hôtels
dont nous voici à strasbourg au
parlement européen
reportage cette semaine nous emmène à
angresse où la crise sociale s'aggrave
le taux de chômage explose la grèce
pour le gouvernement à décider sans
prévenir personne de fermer la
télévision publique
mais d'abord à l'actualité après
plusieurs années de récession 57
millions d'européens vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté
alors le rap s'enfonce taille dans la
misère et c'est la question de la
semaine
pas question de colère
initié par pierre lopes
quant aux grèves du port
en espagne et en irlande
finalement on s'y habitue réplique
pas vraiment
de retour à la case misère pour
l'union européenne
les buts immobilières ont explosé
jeudi dans les rues des familles
entières et en attendant
on regarde mourir des villages fantômes
même les autoroutes sont désertés
alors qu'elle était mineure
le plan de sauvetage
la rigueur budgétaire
c'est le retour de la misère eneurope
et nous voilà de retour à strasbourg
au parlement européen nous allons
parler de
le de retour de la misère en aura pas
et de poursuivre que cette question fait
karima delli qui est avec nous mais en
juin prochain m vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe d avec les
acteurs et surtout
membres de la commission belot points et
des affaires sociales et pour louvoyer
ces images d'émeutes de manifestation
quand on voyait par exemple agacé par
la cession depuis plus de cinq ans
maintenant
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque ce que
vont là avec greg c'est au niveau des
conditions de vie au sein de l'union
européenne à la précarité a explosé
la pauvreté explosé et cette concerne
toutes les catégories de population que
ce soit les jeunes les retraités
même les familles monoparentales
aujourd'hui
eh bien ça veut dire que le cap pour
ces données notamment le caf
que la commission et les chefs d'état
s'étaient guère le cas de
l'austérité
et pas le bon cap aujourd'hui il faut
penser plutôt à des investissements
pas à couper dans les dépenses mais
véritablement investir pour pouvoir
redonner un peu espoir alençon des
populations et créer des filets de
sécurité
et à ce moment-là on verra
réellement une bouffée d'oxygène et
quand je parle de
filet de sécurité on ne peut pas
parler de la pauvreté et demi de la
misère
sans les populations parce que
malheureusement
souvent fait plus haut
alors qu'aujourd'hui faut faire avec
elle
la bouche nez dehors rendra leur apport
qui a été le seul des six skieurs se
connecter il a eu du mal à aller voter
sur la question du logement à l'europe
le logement non ce n'est pas une
compétence de l'union européenne et de
surcroît le parlement européen a
accueilli n'a pas vocation en fait à
proposer des directives
et c'est un pavé dans la mare
c'est un pavé dans la marre c'est la
première fois que le parlement s'engage
de manière aussi claire pour dire nous
avons besoin du logement le social
l'ofsp
le logement ce n'est pas une compétence
de l'union européenne et nous avons
r le droit aline et de logement c'est
une obligation parce que c'est un droit
qui est reconnu par la charte des droits
fondamentaux
henkel a plu le logement apl
atari rassure
différents o'donnell l'efficacité
énergétique et le volet emploi le
volet
lutte contre l'exclusion le volet m en
servir l'intérêt général
aides d'état excepté rares
et dans mon rapport justement pour la
première fois
ladies député européen demande
ats le cadre européen des politiques du
logement notamment du logement social
pour véritablement avancez
pour plus de logements récession
mais aussi à hanter sur cette pente
sociale
là vous avez pointé dans ce rapport la
question d'hommes de la spéculation
immobilière au début on l'a vu
notamment l'irlande on l'a vu en espagne
surtout
on assiste en fait avec
on voit aujourd'hui des villages
fantômes qui sont complètement vide on
estime qu'à 700 mille logements en
espagne qui sont en europe aujourd'hui
n'avait occupé
mais en l'état aujourd'hui comment vous
régler cette question là alors très
simplement le rapport du bien
quel plus on aura un parc de logements
sociaux importants plus on va éviter
les bulles immobilières
ça veut dire que vous dites stop aux
propriétaires quoi la gamme en 10
heures elle ment aujourd'hui il faut
plus de logements sociaux parce que
c'est un véritable levier pour lutter
contre la crise sociale la crise
économique
mais aussi la crise écologique et face
notamment à un vrai problème vous
évoquiez notamment à l'espagne
aujourd'hui dans le rapport ont dit
clairement
il faut lutter contre les expulsions
notamment des familles qui n'arrivent
plus
à payer leur crédit
hypothéquer rc été reconnue
notamment par la cour européenne de
justice ait reconnu
par le parlement on repère
maintenant il est temps même s'il a
voté un moratoire de deux ans sur les
expulsions vous vous souvenez bien que
ceux-ci soient généralisable sur tout
le territoire on a hâte
on a reçu plusieurs expérimentations
au niveau européen on a essayé de le
demander
notamment de mettre en place justement
des politiques de prévention et
d'éviter les expulsions
on l'a relancé battu au parlement mais
malheureusement les conservateurs
et les libéraux sont encore dans une
logique du tous propriétaires qui
malheureusement
elle nous emmène des armées dans le
mur il n'a pas été adopté
mais cela n'est pas très grave puisque
dans le rapport on trouve également
une protection qui est majeur notamment
pour les prix
population et plus
il est plus que précaire
notamment ces de lutter contre la
vacance des logements aujourd'hui n'y a
pas assez de logements sociaux
il faut construire donc il faut lutter
contre la vacance et des logements et
pour la première fois le parlement
européen
demanda à l'ensemble des états membres
de fixer un quota minimum
de logements sociaux notamment dans les
zones
tandis que vous voyez là il n ya rien
à vendre une application de la loi et
de faire comme telle qu'on la connaît
la france qui obligeait en fait les
communes à avoir 25 % de logements
sociaux sur leur territoire
mais cela au niveau européen
voilà que si je comprends bien en vue
où les militants de jeudi noir qui est
donc une association
qui que se posent sur ce champ du
logement et notamment du logement social
vous êtes en train de donner plutôt un
satisfecit à la france sur la manière
dont elle gère la question du logement
on peut faire crédit à la france
qu'elle avançait
notamment cette question de logement
social mais elle ne va pas assez loin
parce qu'on ne construit pas en ait pas
aujourd'hui dans les objectifs atteints
de maladies hautement va pas les
atteintes c'était cette année
et moi j'ai tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
sur le fait qu'en france le faire aussi
beaucoup plus de logement très sociaux
parce que malheureusement l'accès à
des logements
sociaux est de plus en plus c'est un
parcours du combattant pour les jeunes
les plus précaires les plus pauvres
on voit bien quand même qu'on est dans
une conjoncture budgétaire très
contraint de céder
le budget européen qui sera peut-être
en passe d'être adopté le mois
prochain
pêche considérablement les crédits
pour 100 euros fourchette
parce qu'on peut pas dire que votre
rapport et ses voeux de
dede de pointer les fonds structurels
sur la question du logement sur cette
précarité énergétique est ce que
c'est pas un voeu pieux
ce n'est pas le cas parce que d'une part
l'union européenne ils estiment déjà
vous allez font respecter mal
dans le logement social aujourd'hui nous
sommes en pleine tête la négociation
notamment si le
le fléchage des fonds européens ou
huit c'est sera une priorité l'union
européenne va avec est inerte davantage
la liga les fonds structurels dans le
logement social
également dans le logement privé et il
ya aussi notamment des
réinvestissements
parole à des banques publiques à des
investissements dans ce qu'on appelle la
villa dei voyez on est en train
d'avancer mais je voudrais juste
assisté sur un nouveau fléau parce que
pour cent et je pense que je sais c'est
maintenant qu'il faut tirer la scène
d'alarmé avec deux chiffres
il ya aujourd'hui en iran contre 50 et
125 millions
des personnes qui sont dans une
précarité
énergétique qui n'arrive plus à
s'échauffer spinal tap
notamment leurs factures hélas c'est
une question de degré de masse
thermique eva le rappeur finances déjà
justement
cette rénovation thermique et a permis
dans l'espace de deux heures
la rénovation de 70000 logements
sociaux en france
et la création directe et puis les 15
minutes
entre locaux
non délocalisables casadebaig août et
merci beaucoup caravelle et je rappelle
effectivement tête
on est ici à 57 millions de requins qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
donc effectivement c'est un grand
chantier pour la l'union
et pour les parlementaires
merci karima delli d'avoir celle qui
était notre invité aujourd'hui on
continue sur les sept émissions sur
laquelle son aciérie
vous savez que bachar el assad est
accusé par la communauté
internationale d'utiliser des armes
chimiques
dans son pays et nous avons voulu savoir
comment les télévisions étrangères
avec traiter la question c'est un rating
réalisé par aurélie la face
problèmes respiratoires
philatélie les lycées des hôpitaux
syriens sont surtout les écrans
comme autant de preuves de l'utilisation
des armes chimiques dans le pays
sur l'a10 d'ici cet habitant témoin
12 heures
s'il y avait une odeur suffocante
horrible on ne pouvait plus du tout
risquer tout mon corps était comme
fatigué ils perdaient tous ses sens
on avait l'impression d'être mort je
n'y voyais plus rien si je n'ai plus
rien vu pendant trois ou quatre jours
tokyo international il est exact une
position et c'est de s'organiser et mais
ce n'est pas encore une priorité
la case départ la grande-bretagne a
annoncé détenir des preuves sur
concernant l'utilisation de gaz sarin
preuve confirmée par la france
qui n'exclut pas l'intervention
militaire
pendant ce temps la rencontre entre les
etats-unis et la russie et l'onu a
débuté à genève pour préparer la
conférence internationale sur la syrie
un peu léger mais deux dont la date n'a
pas encore été fixée
pas de date une conférence
internationale il est au niveau
européen comme toujours
pas de position commune
l'embargo sur les armes élevé mais
ensuite libre à chaque étape dans
livrer ou non
la rtbf vu ces derniers temps
l'indécision bruxelloise en 18 parties
mickaël bisous par là devant les
caméras les patrons des différentes
diplomatie européenne donne presque
l'impression d'une parfaite harmonie
ce n'est qu'une illusion une fois
réunis ils affichent leurs divergences
pour en arriver à ce qui se passait
les européens ont échoué à cas sur
la question syrienne c'est nicolas
gros-verheyde qui étaient avec nous
pour en parler merci d'être avec nous
bonjour bonjour vous êtes spécialisé
questions de défense notamment sur
l'union européenne eyi par cet ailleurs
si je puis dire et vous
nous disait vous dirigez le blogue
bruxelles de point de vue comme vous
voyez ces images de
des phases de responsables européens
qui se font effectivement la
muet qui sont dans une certaine
léthargie sur la question
syrienne qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
qui respire que depuis deux ans on parle
de solutions politiques depuis deux ans
les européens ont nommé m
prix 1 en place pour une solution
politique
du coup on ne discute que l'embargo sur
les armes alors qu'on devrait discuter
un plan de paix
envoi d émissaires
de solutions intermédiaires
conférence internationale ce qui est la
solution politique
pour l'instant les européens n'ont mis
en place rien de tout ça et pourtant la
ligue arabe a renvoyé à un émissaire
de failles et ramène les deux ou trois
qui ont chacun démissionné devant elle
l'impossibilité de la tâche dont 4
est-ce qu'il est encore une solution
politique la ligue arabe effectivement
pas l'union européenne oui
pour moi y'a encore on n'a pas essayé
tous les poulets d'acteurs de la
solution politique le problème c'est
qu'il faut associer
tous les acteurs de la région
donc a pas de londres on ne l'exclût
pas des acteurs qui est l'iran qui est
un acteur principal
on exclut toute solution politique donc
ça ne sert à rien
de parler de solution politique sur une
dalle pas en gros oui le dialogue qui se
passe pas avec les amis
il se passe avec les ennemis
donc il faut associer d'iran il faut
associer le hesbollah
la partie libanaise et le hezbollah
voire voir toutes les parties c'est
vraiment associé
avec des intermédiaires nôtre on peut
pas demander au qatar à la barrière à
bisséous dutoit la russie aux
états-unis d'accès internet est
imposé notre
il faut trouver le bon intermédiaire
neutre pour assurer la réunion des deux
parties
ce qui est classique on associe chorale
kembs hengy au milieu des nôtres les
européens où certains se repère
qu'auraient pu jouer les notes qu'ils
ont pas joué les nôtres ourquoi parce
qu'il est issu en faible parce qu'ils
sont enfermés qu'ils sont impuissants
parce qu'ils ne valent pas
et qui longe le tout le discours en
selle la question de la scierie c'est
quoi c'est la régionalisation du
conflit on est dans un espace de maistre
veut pas s'en mêler c'est parce que je
pense qu'il a un manque de volonté on
le tout la solution européenne était
dire qu'on appuie les efforts de l'onu
et la ligue arabe
et en gros en europe fait tout ce qu'on
peut pour ça
mais ça ne suffit pas si on veut être
un acteur
on doit pas appuyer les les efforts d'un
autre acteur on doit proposer ses
services
je pense que là c'est une erreur
fondamentale des européens
là au moins on assiste aussi %
aujourd'hui à hassel these
franchissement de la ligne rouge dedans
barack obama par là qui est
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques
on a quand même de plus en plus de
preuves sur l'utilisation notamment du
gaz par an
% la question de la halle levée de
l'embargo
fait de la livraison d'armes a été
posée qu'en est -il en fait de tout
salarié de shopzilla
les armes chimiques
dany rouge tignes rouge bidon fois les
très clair il n'y a pas de lignes
rouges y'a rien dans le droit
international qui dit que quand rien de
chimique on a le droit d'en payer la
pension damas qui l'a dit si obama
remettra si on avait logé et est
arrivé dans ma carrière à ce
moment-là mais ça c'est une ligne
rouge bidon qui est et qui d'ailleurs
s'est écroulé au moment la ligne rouge
a été franchie c'est comme quand vous
franchissez la ligne jaune personnes
d'assister donc vous pouvez rouler donc
ya eu un feu vert à l'envoi d'armes
chimiques amirouche transformant en feu
vert ça c'est le premier fait pour moi
la ligne rouge a déjà été franchi
quand on viole le droit international
militaire c'est ça la vraie ligne rouge
la brune ou rousse quant au moment des
hôpitaux on compte plus de 6000 des
enfants qu'on s'attaque aux autres au
médecin pour atteindre tous les efforts
de contre attaque pas uniquement aux
combattants donc la ligne rouge est
franchie depuis
de plusieurs temps la vraie ligne rouge
en fait
je pense pour la plupart des acteurs
internationaux c'est que le conflit ne
déborde pas violemment de rang des
frontières et pourtant la gallardo aux
jo qu'elle lève le nez en est quand
même un peu touché en tant que ça
reste un jeu
donc ça reste un peu touché sa part
tant qu'ils ont fait
pour les américains la vraie ligne
rouge pense que c'est israël
pour les russes la vallée rouge leurs
bases
donc tant ces deux grosses lignes rouges
sont pas franchies
personne ne leur en donne bougera parce
que personne n'a intérêt à bouger les
russes bloc toute façon toute
résolution au conseil de sécurité
les occidentaux ne veulent pas passer en
dehors du conseil de sécurité la
leçon d'irak a payé
pour l'instant le conflit
continue il continuera d'avoir des morts
on est à cent mille morts
les armes chimiques ont fait un certain
nombre de morts mais n'ont pas fait
l'essentiel des morlaix les sens et des
morts est fait par des hommes
conventionnel
tant que les syriens se battent dans
leur pays
pour la communauté internationale
fotini qu'il y a pas de problème
merci nicolas grau d'agde soirée
théâtrale été de nouveau continué
avant de retrouver cassagnabère et son
invité direction la grèce
après cinq ans de crise nous avons
été à la rencontre d'un peuple à
l'agonie ciel là-bas le taux de suicide
a augmenté de 26 % en une année
c'est un reportage de florence mauricien
et de pablo sakata baisse
si 20 avril 2012
un pharmacien retraité criblé de
dettes
ce suicide à deux pas du parlement grec
un geste politique
pour dénoncer l'austérité
c'est une
c'est une grande
cela aurait pu être la nôtre nous ça
aurait pu être quelqu'un de notre
famille si ça continue nous allons tous
nous suicider
prennent soudain conscience de la crise
morale qui secoue leur pays
aïkido une association d'aidé aux
surendettés
on a pris très tôt la mesure de ce
malaise
d'ici là le sage liste bénévoles
viennent pas en aide aux victimes des
coupes budgétaires
pas marrant et 22e
mariana ap poussez la porte en 2011
sapin à l'époque je me sentais
coupable
c'est extrêmement peu peur
je me disais que j'avais fait beaucoup
d'erreurs la pocatière
j'étais totalement désespérée c'est
une certitude la maison moi je ne
voulais plus me battre pour lui je
voudrais tout le temps j'ai été
envahie par la tristesse une profonde
envie d'autodestruction
parmi les personnes suivies avec
lisandro quatre se sont déjà suicidé
les bénévoles ont même dû faire
appel à des psychologues pour les aider
à soutenir les plus désespérés
comme beaucoup mariana se croyait à
l'abri
elle était fonctionnaire
un emploi stable
bien payé
aujourd'hui elle ignore si elle pourra
garder cet appartement acheté à
crédit
après des années de croissance
insouciante en grèce
la crise a fait vaciller ses certitudes
brad cabana canard
en fait je n'ai rien fait tout assad a
contacté j'ai juste agit comme tout le
monde
reprise
il faut se souvenir qu'à cette
époque-là les banques nous envoyer des
offres de prêts tous les jours
mariana refait surface grâce au soutien
psychologique sur les divisions
beaucoup n'ont pas cette chance
dans une grève très religieuse
le suicide reste un sujet tabou pour
consulter est une décision difficile
coûteuse au cices
le secteur de la santé est à l'agonie
un tiers des grecs n'a plus d'assurance
maladie
ce centre médical a été créé en
2011 pour répondre à l'urgence
dans la matinée collaborateurs du site
elle vient de jadis
visite des médecins bénévoles se
relaient
pour offrir gratuitement ce soir les
médicaments
vous exclus du système de santé
cette année le festival merci beaucoup
maria est psychologue
elle consulte l'issue de cinq heures par
semaine
pour le qatar et oman
je sens qu'il ya vraiment des choses qui
se sont débloquées en moins
on ignore si le bénéficiaire
baby-sitting fin de sa vie si tous les
jours voir les débris et des médias
qui oppose alors qu'il devrait peser 4
sortie nord
mais que beaucoup de gens considèrent
le soutien psychologique comme un luxe
dans ce chaos ambiant
on est en train de fabriquer et la
génération de grecs désemparés et en
colère pour répondre aux graves pour
éviter de vider la jeunesse de tout son
potentiel de toutes ses capacités il
n'est pas certain c'est un génocide
en deux ans
la consommation d'antidépresseurs a
bondi en grèce
celle de drogue aussi
tout comme les contaminations vais y
acheter
deux fois par semaine place omonia un
médecin du monde accueil des
toxicomanes alors que le budget prévu
ce congrès
la grèce à même sa nouvelle drogue
l'a6a
composé de liquide de batterie et de
détergents préparer
et j'ai des amis qui entraîne
régulièrement
en deux ans d'utilisation ils sont plus
apparus comme après 20 ans d'héroïne
je suis déjà allé les voir chez eux
ils deviennent fous il se tape la tête
contre les murs c'est totalement irréel
à voir
2 euros le shoot contre salzbourg de
l'héroïne
l'a6a l adrar de la crise
tous les indicateurs sont au rouge
mais la grèce s'accroche à ces valeurs
refuges
les religions
depuis le début de la crise le père
thomas est sur tous les fronts
il a triplé ses distributions de
nourriture il multiplie les activités
à destination des enfants
mais en fait tu ne savais même pas que
des vcs une fois qu'on aura dépassé la
crise je crois que la situation serait
meilleure qu'avant
les gens ont dû renoncer à
l'individualisme absolument il renouait
avec la solidarité des plateaux il sait
quelque chose qu'on avait perdu
après six années de récession
la grèce espère une timide reprise
économique en 2014
mais nul ne sait encore combien de temps
ou deux générations il faudra
pour réparer la crise morale qui mine
le pays
reportage signé florence maurice a
athènes avec une il y a
souple
crise économique sociale et sanitaire
la grèce est au coeur de l'actualité
et on n'en parle avec notre invité
boniface à bonjour m pour vous et vos
députés grecs du parti populaire
européen qui regroupe la droite et de
centre-droite
ici au parlement européen vous êtes
membre de la commission des affaires
économiques
il monétaire cette semaine coup de
théâtre en grèce puisque % mais il
annonce que la fermeture de
la radio-télévision
publique la police il montait sur la
montagne pour eux éteindre l'émetteur
principal % et de la télévision
elle sent que les journalistes aient le
temps de dire au revoir c'est anna
cappellini quand l'europe puisque c'est
la dernière fois que cette époque
c'était
en 1967 avec la dictature des colonels
est ce que peuvent vous c'est une
violation de la démocratie
du côté des faits pas des comparaisons
pareille
l'allemagne a fait plein pays en
récession économique 6e amiens de
récession économique
et ça c'est un très bon score votre
rapporteur
à la boutique
de l'autre côté
il ya une prise de conscience
aujourd'hui chez le caractère
je sais pas si d'autres un portage a pu
constater ça aussi
les 400 dans les cafés soro dans les
appareils dans les familles
r autour de la famille pouls des fêtes
familiales pour des fêtes a fallu
joueuses et ils ont une confiance pour
l'avenir madrelle acquise tristesse
malgré la souffrance
et là sur cette décision il est
difficile de cerner la holding vous
imaginez comment alors la décision
inédite et là la situation est
difficile
et le gouvernement
après tant de temps tentative
des restes culturel mais chaque carte
publique
des radios et télévisions c'est un
secteur à nord
lyon en productique
nos compétiteurs
a pris la décision
après des grèves quand tu n'es pas ce
que mam malgré les cinq enfants qui
réellement unie elle n'était pas
toujours et partout à cause de grève
continue
il a pris les décisions de faire mal et
certains
et elle de préparer déjà le projet
est là
l'ouverture de la création
dell entre secteurs avec -3 de personnes
mortes moins de personnel
mais m
merci de respecter notre opération
réalisée
le buste que modère
à quand même satisfaire
au besoin
d'un service public
mais pour apaiser autant
aux contribuables gracq est-ce que le
gouvernement
des actifs
qui a surpris tout le monde de court en
prenant cette décision n'aurait pas pu
quand même
informés
avant les salariés puisque même
l'union européenne a été surprise
le président de l'ue
vous pouvez laisser passer la crise je
ne partage pas moi je peux pas vous
parler de la communication de lady
cette communication or entre les
secteurs publics telle débâcle
l à l'association européenne ça je ne
peux pas vous dire que c'était mais
doit gérer avec d'inévitables ça je
ne peux pas vous dire c'est qu'il a
été nécessaire cette facture
malgré
la réaction des fonctionnaires on peut
très bien comprendre quelqu'un qui par
son travail
mais il ya quand même dans une partie
de la presse et ap et de la population
en tête une satisfaction qui est à
même de garam bouleversements qui va
à rationaliser les
secteur public parce que pour le moment
les effets de la crise de l'austérité
de cette adaptation rapide budgétaire
sellette la mls acteurs privés de tout
plaquer
guillaumin a rééquilibré le chômage
c'est dans le secteur privé
alors si on demande aux entreprises
privées
défaire leur corps est opérationnel de
rationaliser et de fair-play les
exportations des faire plus de choses
avec moi - du moment des frais
imaginez comment
ce secteur privé
qui ne voit maisé sus les épaules
cette adaptation de cette crise
elle exige du gouvernement
de mettre à table de ferme 900 ménages
dans place acteurs
mais malgré ça
il ya il n'ya plus une prise c'est un
rapport
de liste grand secteur de
radio-télévision
ils ne seront pas dehors ils seront
hissés au rang
les services enfants comme x-men x-men
d'abord une priorité
outre le concours d'entrée
dans le même temps la nouvelle
structure qui va mettre en place par
mégarde bientôt
et de notre côté heene le repas doit
se passer de l'aide concours ou des
services
qui embauchent encore comme les
hôpitaux
les services sociaux
quand on voit notre reportage on se dit
que
de l'état du pays et quand même et
quand même grave qu'elle ait dit m et
difficile de ce qu'est un chris semet
certains on voit pourtant cinq
économistes prédisent un retour de la
croissance en 2014 est ce que vous
croyez qu'on nie cependant prenez ce
parcours on travaille pour ça
mais vous savez
il faut prendre soin d elle mesure
difficile
des décisions difficiles
et sectaire
parlant de cette technique en ce temps
que le gouvernement doit faire m
en entrant
aaa alarm
la rationalisation économique et
budgétaire
t mais aime la protection
des travailleurs
galasso société
b&b des genres date d'achat majeur
c'est toujours difficile vous pouvez
comprend pas en revanche de cire
comment c'est difficile de prendre des
mesures
kano - de l'air voix est urgent et
nécessaire
parce que il aura un coût social
la politique
l'usiné secret et qui est très souvent
insupportable
voilà du lourd
arnaque tous les jours des décisions de
pareilles décisions apprends
en même temps les politiques et
vérité appliqués et pour la grèce
depuis des années son son impôt remise
en cause le fonds monétaire
international à lui-même reconnu qu'il
avait peut-être fait fausse route en
imposant une austérité aussi aussi
fort que ce que c'est le cas voilà vous
savez
moi je critiquais même mère
eldar et se voit plateau plusieurs fois
elle programme appliqué en grèce
au début
tout le monde a cru que c'était
loïc caracalla xperience international
à trotter et l'union européenne comme
opérateur pour les verts et banque
centrale relève qui ont une expérience
international l intérêt d art des
résultats positifs ont rapidement
et le programme et les bons il faut les
suivre
nous les autres partis la contester
dès le premier moment les de ce
programme
et parce que les galettes laisse pas
prendre un annuaire laissé là-bas il
n'était pas équilibrée
dans les biens volés prospérité
la dette nette de 3 405
mais cela
on est là aujourd'hui il faut s'en
sortir
et que c'est très difficile
pour la classe politique
et pour la société grecque
c ette nos soucis quotidiens mais cette
aide je peux vous dire secteur
le gouvernement doit l'être à l'avant
elles sont réelles il n'a pas le choix
d'aller à l'arrière mais la société
traqueur
elle elle est très solidaire où la
bête depuis que constater que ce poids
et cette solidarité vraiment elle est
très nécessaire
vous donnez cette question voir projo
non seulement des supports tels que les
fardc
leur plan pour le lendemain
eh bien merci beaucoup rodica cela se
fait raser appelé le modèle votre
intérêt l écart et que vous portez
halak à la grève et à la société
d'abord laissé aller dans l'hémicycle
ce qu'il ya des votes en ce moment-même
c'est la fin de cette émission je vous
souhaite une très bonne suite de
programmes
et rendez-vous la semaine prochaine sur
la chaîne parlementaire pour un autre
numéro de rater deux
kerner